all right let's look at a couple of
interviews from the last 24 hours from
the two men who if they both run are are
the likely Front Runners in the 2024
Republican primary we're going to start
with Ron DeSantis and then look at
Donald Trump Ron DeSantis is on what
according to many is a very ill-advised
trip to Asia right now flooding and gas
lines in Florida
um all sorts of problems that are uh
self-inflicted quite frankly by Ron
DeSantis and he was in Japan yesterday
and I believe now in Korea really a
profile and courage in in South Korea
that has you you might imagine and
during the Hannity hour last night on
Fox News which I guess coincides
conveniently with the time difference
with where Ron DeSantis is Ron DeSantis
was interviewed now there's a logistical
problem and then there's a substance
problem the logistical problem as you
will notice is that somehow they set
DeSantis up
facing the Sun and he's squinting the
entire interview he looks visibly
uncomfortable now DeSantis often looks
visibly uncomfortable even in a well-lit
cool room but here he looks extra
uncomfortable so I don't know you know
this was a scheduled interview why they
have him staring into the sun I don't
really know maybe it's because Trump
stared at the eclipse that time and they
wanted to do the same thing unclear but
DeSantis generally
is just not really understanding how to
properly answer basic questions in this
clip Hannity asks DeSantis what happened
to your relationship with Donald Trump
here's his answer the last time I
interviewed president Trump I was there
in 2018
and I always saw the two of you as
friends and I said to him you guys were
friends it's a very simple question I
asked him I said what happened and I
think it's only fair to ask you the same
question what do you think happened
you know I I enjoyed supporting him when
he was President we worked really hard
for his reelection in Florida and I
always had a good relationship with them
and then once the midterm election
happened he started taking shots at me I
didn't really do anything to do it
except do a good job but that's fine I
mean Sean you know when you're making
things happen you take incoming from a
variety of targets so that's just the
nature of the business and I'm happy to
I'm happy to stand strong and do what's
right all right guys I don't think
DeSantis can do it this is such a weak
answer by the standards of what
Republican voters want think of it now
DeSantis isn't wrong listen DeSantis is
accurately pointing out
he used to like me then he stopped
liking me when it became clear that
DeSantis wasn't backing down from
challenging Trump in 2024. this is how
it all started remember that what
happened was DeSantis was asked would
you consider
running in 2024 and would you commit to
only doing it if Trump isn't running and
DeSantis didn't rule out now I might run
even if Trump trump runs I might
challenge Trump this was seen as
disloyal by Trump and that's why all of
this started so desantis's assessment is
100 correct Trump just started going
after me and I'm not going to get
involved in it
this is so pathetic and weak looking
from the standards of these Republican
voters he's basically saying
no he just went after me and I'm doing
nothing
now you and I might say
you need someone taking the high road in
fact it would be better to have someone
who's not even involved in this nonsense
someone like a Mitt Romney or Liz Cheney
or whatever else the case may be I'm
with you on a personal level but this is
weak stuff the this is not going to if
you think Trump's got 52 right now
DeSantis has 24 and in order to win
DeSantis has to figure out some way to
get up to and Beyond 50 percent
this isn't going to help them just yeah
he started it he sounds whiny he sounds
pathetic and the interview continued and
it really isn't great for DeSantis here
um asked again about uh the the attacks
and he says I'm just going to do what's
right that's fine I mean Sean you know
when you're making things happen you
take incoming from a variety of targets
so that's just the nature of the
business and I'm happy to I'm happy to
stand strong and do what's right all
right Governor have a great trip we
appreciate you joining us and okay and I
thought we actually had new stuff there
but it seems sort of like a retread of
of uh a lot of the same stuff so this is
not a guy who you see and you say wow
projecting strength
projecting confidence
projecting an inspiring and electric
alternative Vision to what Trump gives
us hey you know what I was a trump
person maybe I'll go for DeSantis
instead it's maybe good enough to kind
of clean up the hangers on and the dregs
of the uh uh opposition to Trump that is
already there but it's not going to
coalesce people around you and
restructure the dynamic of this Primary
in a way that's going to let you win it
it's just not going to do any of that so
now the question for DeSantis is does he
even announce does he try to wait till
does he forget about the presidency
altogether does he risk possibly
humiliation quite frankly I mean it is
it is totally he really doesn't seem to
have what it takes and if he enters this
race with trumpet 52 and DeSantis at 24
and doesn't have some way to strongly
gain support he could end up truly
humiliated and uh it would be an
entertaining watch from a political
strategy standpoint be sort of a strange
thing so that's the DeSantis interview
from yesterday let's now look at the
Trump interview